[Aplausos]
no hay respiro cuando se trata de Donald
Trump este viernes el departamento de
policía de Nueva York acudió a la
oficina del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan Alvin bracket para retirar
sobres con polvo blanco de naturaleza
desconocida estos sobres fueron enviados
junto a una nota de amenaza al fiscal
que estudia presentar cargos por
supuesto sobornos de Trump a la actriz
de cine para adultos stormy Daniels al
mismo tiempo Trump ha hecho una
incendiaria publicación en su red social
advirtiendo que habrá muerte y
destrucción si se presenta una acusación
en su contra habrá consecuencias
catastróficas según el expresidente que
tilda de psicópata degenerado a quien se
atreva a imputarlo un tono que vuelve a
causar preocupación
La retórica del expresidente que fue
sometido dos veces a juicio político es
temeraria cuestionable e irresponsable
Es peligrosa y así va a ser que maten a
alguien ya hemos visto las consecuencias
de las incitaciones del expresidente
el fiscal Federal de venido en abogado
de Trump Evan corcoren compareció este
viernes ante un gran Jurado Que
Investiga otro de los casos que
involucran al político republicano se
trata de la retención de documentos
clasificados después de dejar la Casa
Blanca además de acuerdo con la cadena
ABC un juez llamará a declarar al ex
jefe de gabinete de Trump Marc middles y
otros antiguos aliados por el tercer
caso que tiene abierto el asalto al
Capitolio muchos frentes de batalla para
quien planea luchar por el premio mayor
el retorno a la Casa Blanca